welcome back to age 20 special
relativity in this section we're going
to further investigate the energy
momentum 4 vector which we introduced in
the previous sections
but here we focus on the zeroest
component the first component of this
vector where we
find mass m a for particle a
times the proper velocity zeroth
component is equal to m a times c times
one
over one minus u a squared over c square
which is the energy of this particle a
over c or in other words the energy is
equal to the mass times c square over
one square root of one minus u a squared
c squared
so let's discuss or look at let's have a
look at this um a little bit more the
first question we can ask how does this
now look like for particles which travel
with a reasonably low velocity so ua
much smaller than c
so we can tailor expand this um
following this equation here which we
discussed earlier
um and we find that the energy is equal
to mac square that's the first term
which we call rest mass the energy given
adjusts the rest mass by the mass of the
particle times c square
plus one half m a c squared times u a
squared over c squared the c squares
cancel
and we find what we known as the kinetic
energy one half m v square or in this
case one half m a u a square
that looks very familiar so the energy
of a particle is given by its rest mass
plus its kinetic energy
all right um now investigating this four
vector then we can ask you know what the
how does the invariant interval look
like
how does this property which is inverant
and the laurel's transformation look
like if we multiply the vector with
itself
here we find minus e square over c
square plus the three momentum squared
is equal to minus m0 c square
or in other words we find this energy
momentum energy mass relation
energy momentum mass relation where the
energy is given by the momentum square
times c square plus the rest mass square
times c to the fourth power
okay again we can unroll this now and
ask you know how does this look for a
particle at rest again we find the
energy is equal to m c square no
surprise that's how we started the
definitions of
this
in general we can find that the energy
is equal to
a relativistic mass times c square which
is equal to the rest mass times gamma
times z square and that's equal to
the rest mass times c square plus k the
kinetic energy square
all right so this definition i can tell
you that this confused me
as a student quite a bit this
understanding that the mass becomes
heavier for particles really one i
didn't quite like i just like to think
about the fact that the kinetic energy
has a relativistic component to the
kinetic energy which is owned by the
particle in addition to the rest mass of
this particle times the square
also interesting to note is that for
particles at rest particles which are
massless like a photon the energy is
equal to the momentum times c
so if you want to know what the what the
energy is of a photon you all you know
you need to know what the momentum is of
the photon multiplied by c